good afternoon my name is Cory Alston
and the CTO of financial services for
Google cloud platform we're very lucky
this afternoon to have Matt Taylor with
us Matt's the CTO of kensho now Matt's
going to do a proper introduction to
himself and to Ken show in a few minutes
but I just wanted to start off by saying
that Ken shows an extraordinary company
that's pioneering real-time statistics
and analytics machine learning for
financial services now Matt and I this
afternoon are going to talk about Ken
show on Google cloud platform machine
learning in your browser and we've got a
real treat because Matt's come up with a
custom tensorflow machine learning model
based on Ken shows data that he's going
to demonstrate for us now we're gonna
split this presentation into two
portions I'm going to lead off
relatively quickly and I'll tell you
about why Google cloud platforms the
best place for you to do your analytics
and machine learning not just a good
option or a good place but the best
place for you to do those activities
Matt's then going to take over and he's
going to talk about Ken show and their
machine learning but I just realized I
made a mistake when I was preparing for
this I didn't sort of take into account
that we'd be doing it right early in the
afternoon so I was lunch for everybody a
good lunch everybody get ready for the
sessions this afternoon and San
Francisco this evening the thumbs up for
lunch all right so I sort of
transparently recovered from my mistake
and now we can go on to some machine
learning modern machine intelligence a
branch of computer science that build
systems to perform similar functions to
human intelligence such as learning
reasoning self correcting and adapting
and it allows us to do some astonishing
things just within financial services
which is my specialization it allows us
to manage risk much more effectively it
allows us to surveil activity much more
effectively it's
essence it promises to be the piece that
was missing for so long where people
thought that financial markets was so
inherently complicated that they
couldn't be understood but you've seen
again we've seen the presentations where
machine learning tensorflow Google cloud
platform give us the opportunity to
bring that understanding to very high
dimensionality data and of course the
caveat is that there's more and more
data the amount of data is increasing
exponentially the the need to make use
of that data is becoming ever more
pressing so we need to scale sometimes
enormous lis and we also need to move
very quickly an experiment and break
stuff very regularly and that's where
Google cloud platform comes in to give
you scale and the ability to iterate
which leads us to a premise the
architecture for analysis and machine
learning I'm not going to spend much
time at all going through the boxes on
this slide apart from saying that each
of these services is fully managed no
operations each of them offers best
functionality wonderful price and
performance what I do just want to spend
a couple of minutes talking about are
the things that I built over the last 12
to 18 months using these building blocks
because that's where the rubber really
hits the road and that was the context
that I wanted to share with you what
I've done can inform what you're gonna
build going forward and hopefully it
will inform what we'll build together
number one I built a proof of concept
using dataflow that took 10,000 30 year
time series of financial data and
correlated everything by everything 50
million correlations of 30 years worth
of data three minutes at 300 thousand
correlations per second
compared to running out on a 16 core
server where I turned it off after 12
hours because it was just if he doesn't
finish in 12 hours that effectively sort
of goes towards infinity to me it was
very boring to wait for it
I built a proof of concept using pub/sub
dataflow cloud storage and big table
that ingested a simulated market data
feed of all North American market data
in graduations of a quarter million
events per second did that from pub/sub
and I also did it as files took about
two days to code that up and it took
zero overhead in setting it up and
ringing it down interestingly I also
built spark clusters to do a grid search
of that data using data proc those
clusters of 25 servers took less than a
minute to come up took about 45 seconds
based on my testing which means I was
able to do that grid search by
instantiating and then tearing down
whole clusters of machines finally and
recently we built a machine learning
model that spans spark'd ml and
tensorflow to put an ensemble together
to see how those things worked and with
that I wanted to hand it over to Matt
who's going to talk about what Ken chose
doing thank you very much
Thank You Cory our partnership with
Google on GCP has been a real pleasure I
think one of the things that attracted
us to Google was the collaborative
nature in which we get to develop our
products he's also done a fantastic job
of kind of showing off the raw power
that GCP provides to us so today I'm
gonna give you a personal look under the
hood of kensho what our mission is how
we think about the world and most
importantly we'll walk through a machine
learning experiment together letting the
computer identify what days are like
this so kensho is a high-end analytics
platform for the financial industry
think machine-learning powered hedge
fund analytics delivered via the browser
if you work at a major bank or a major
hedge fund you've probably already aware
of our platform if you've watched CNBC
you've likely seen the kensho stats box
where their anchors use our platform to
analyze events in the news
while we deliver hedge fund caliber
analytics we're not a hedge fund and
that's one of the nice things that I can
do today is as a start-up as a
technology company I can come and give
you a peek under the hood of how we
treat financial analysis this is making
sophisticated financial analysis more
accessible intuitive and beautiful now
as part of a kensho team and a back-end
nerd a data nerd at heart I'm passionate
about deleting code and using technology
to understand the world machine learning
accomplishes both of these goals
I joined ten show in 2013 and I now
quarterback the engineering data science
and design teams and every day I rely
heavily on my experience building
low-level financial infrastructure high
frequency trading and delivering
millions of cat gifs at tumblr kensho
and our machine learning on Google cloud
platform is the unity of these goals
make it smart make it fast and make it
beautiful
now founded in 2013 kensho like almost
like any almost three-year-old were
curious about the world we come with few
preconceived notions were eager to learn
and we adapt quickly to new information
we do this via search discovery analysis
knowledge graph event database we deal
with single assets macro events
geopolitical weather and today we're
going to ask the machine to identify
days like this so like any good
experiment we are going to start with a
testable hypothesis we're gonna plan for
our experiment we're gonna structure a
specific test and we're gonna let the
Machine drive our analysis then we're
gonna feed it back into the kensho
platform and see how the markets react
so if you've read a random walk down
Wall Street and believed in efficient
market theory you probably think that
the answer is no if you recall the
financial crisis and the Great Recession
you might think asset prices can be
grossly mispriced for prolonged periods
of time you might think the answer is
yes using market events and other
features can I gain insight into what
may happen tomorrow let's find out what
the computer thinks in order to maximize
learning there's two things that we
really need and for hungry lean
companies the most important question is
what is the most valuable thing I can
learn right now and the two things I
need our resources and proper timing so
I want to take a step back for a second
and talk about those two things to make
sure now is the time to act now for
resources I borrow a lot from the same
challenging questions that face our own
education system about educating our
best and brightest to keep America
competitive and across a global
marketplace you need physical safety to
explore and experience what the world is
around you you need resources to fuel
and encourage and to grow with you you
need a community of mentors guides and
helping you correct your mistakes you
need a culture that encourages you to
learn from mistakes to try lots of
things and to fail quickly but above all
you have to always be learning and if we
apply this same approach to how we teach
our machines and then how our machines
teach us right data center security CPU
disk and network capacity unparalleled
access to api's data the right
permissions to not do the wrong things
we can do a really powerful stuff that
becomes a tipping point in the ecosystem
where it feeds back onto itself and
becomes a multiplier now the second
thing we need in addition to Reese
was timing and this is critical and one
of the things that struck me was
thinking about one of my favorite things
in all the world the Large Hadron
Collider it took ten years to build it
ten years from 1998 to 2008 it was a
significant international collaborative
effort by CERN it needed years of
theoretical testing and at smaller
attempts to build smaller colliders it
didn't have its first test run until
2010 but it all paid off in 2012 they
discovered the Higgs boson and is now
being used to measure some of the
highest energy collisions in the world
I want to compare that to what kensho
gets from GCP instead of investing a
generation of knowledge and science and
instead of investing a half decade of
infrastructure build-out in another
decade to actually get it running we
spend minutes we measure our scientific
process in minutes of time and money
founded in 2013 we use machine learning
on GCP to power our platform now what
struck me at this is Google was founded
in 1998 as well the same year they
started building the Large Hadron
Collider and while we can run countless
experiments every day and scale up those
experiments to the largest in the world
like asked myself why are we able to do
this how can we go from a generation of
planning to doing science and data
science and research and machine
learning in minutes we're standing on
top of the other thing that started in
1998 Google has more than a decade of
building out infrastructure security
data expertise and it struck me at
yesterday's keynote Diane green
mentioned that Google spends nine point
nine billion dollars every year on capex
and it cost approximately nine point
nine billion dollars to build the Large
Hadron Collider
so we are standing upon the Large Hadron
Collider equivalent of cloud computing
and that means we can start signing
customers solving our problems and doing
machine learning without having to build
17 miles of tunnel underneath Europe so
if we have resources and we have the
timing is right because we can do our
experiments measured in minutes and we
can do those experiments in parallel
with everyone else who wants to use this
Large Hadron Collider at the same time
it's clearly the time to get started so
let's move right away to designing our
experiment so the first thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna gather various
measures of sector performance their
momentum liquidity volatility pricing
trends historical ranges of prices we're
gonna want to normalize that data
perhaps into log space we're gonna
adjust the ranges of the data to prevent
outliers from squishing our data into
buckets that prevent them from being
distinguished from each other then we're
going to use unsupervised machine
learning to identify key features that
have existed in market days previous to
this then we're going to use
unsupervised machine learning to cluster
those and identify what days are most
similar to each other and then we're
going to take this model feed it back
into kensho and we're gonna ask what
will happen the next day
so let's recall our hypothesis
so now we're gonna take a moment to ask
you to log out of your retirement
accounts while machine learning is
amazingly powerful and an amazingly cool
I'm an engineer not a financial adviser
don't J trade your retirement account so
the first thing I said we were gonna do
is we're gonna gather and normalize our
data we do this in a compositional API
driven fashion that is powered by Google
cloud platform in this case we take a
configuration and we inject it with time
series information event from our
knowledge base and our event Almanac
measures of price and momentum and
liquidity and behind the scenes we're
going to normalize and clean up that
data I said this would just be the good
parts this compositional style of
machine learning means we can leverage
all that Google has to offer in one
notebook in this case I'm pulling in
almost 4,300 days of market data with
about 64 features for every day so we
love matrices and so do computers and so
does machine learning models in this
case we're using single value
decomposition to remove redundant data
I'm not helping the computer very much
here this is the computer telling me hey
I found some stuff you really didn't
need to include it's not that valuable
and in this case SVD says I can remove a
chunk of your information and still keep
almost 98% of the distinguishing
characteristics I'm asking the computer
literally to say what can I throw away
the next thing we're going to do is
throw this into a model called T sneak
in longer form its T distributed
stochastic neighbor embedding this
reduces the dimensionality of the data
from 64 dimensions down to 2 but it does
not preserve the state of the data it is
helpful for plotting it in a human
understandable space but I do want to
emphasize in just a couple lines of code
have told the computer almost nothing
I'm challenging the computer to tell me
I'm gonna continue to be very lazy I'm
not gonna pick or estimate the number of
clusters that we should use beforehand
I'm not gonna make consumptions about
the internal data structure affinity
propagation essentially says what
information is passed from previous
States in the data to future States and
the computer will figure this out on its
own as we layer these clusters in
two-dimensional space the silhouette
score will give us essentially what it
sounds like it is an overlay of the data
and to what extent do the shadows or
silhouettes of those clusters overlap or
fit with each other now a terrible fit
would say I'm in a cluster but I really
belong in some other cluster and a great
fit would say I'm so happy in my current
cluster I would never want to be
anywhere else it's not even close and
the scores for a silhouette range from
negative 1 to 1 in this case we have a
0.15 that's we're doing ok I've seen
better we can continue to improve it so
let's visualize this in two dimensions
this is a pretty graph there's some
larger areas where a lot of days appear
similar there's some tighter clusters
that seem to be really close together
now potential deals so much with
historical precedence that for me I'm
drawn to the clusters that have a lot of
days this allows me to go back and
measure things that have hundreds of
days and similarity but taking a moment
that I've already learned something here
I can go pluck out clusters that only
have to win or three days in them and
just the fact that these days seem to be
so distinguished from all the others can
make them notable as well if as the
market day rolls on I find the most
similar days are one of these tiny
clusters that seems to not be similar to
anything else that can potentially be
valuable information all by itself so as
the computer starts organizing and
sorting your data and giving you
perspective
on what is common versus uncommon it
gives you the power as a human to make a
judgment about is this rare and if it's
rare what do I do
or maybe it just sounded rare and now
the computer is telling me no this
happens all the time we ran into this
with the drop of price of oil we went
from about a hundred and forty dollars
dropped to a hundred dollars and there
was there was a big discussion around
that because a forty dollar drop in oil
is enormous but is it and we were able
to use kensho to show that it wasn't an
unusual event it wasn't a buying
opportunity it was a there was room for
it to drop because on a percentage basis
oil dropping twenty or thirty percent
was not uncommon and as the summer went
on oil dropped to $70 to $60 and more
recently it was down in the 30s so just
the quantity and how rare something is
is valuable by itself so let's look at a
specific day and in this case I have
chosen February 23rd so about a month
ago this this particular cluster has a
couple hundred precedents in it and in
this case I'm looking at other dates and
I've bucketed them by month in machine
learning as the feeble human who's
participating in this task I find
histograms immensely useful because it
gives me a sense of the shape of the
data how it's laid out how the computer
has organized it for me and then I can
look at this and say that's interesting
so what's interesting about it well for
one I see there's a lot more days like
February 23rd more recently this junk in
2014 and 2015
I don't see much in 2010 2011 2012
little spike in 2008
not much in 2007 and then I go back into
the early thoughts I see there's more
clusters of data and intuitively I find
this makes sense
the regime of the market from the
financial crisis to about 2014 or early
15 was a long steady march up to the
right though he's recovering from the
Great Recession people's confidence was
going up the stock market was earnings
were strong right revenue growth was
strong the housing market was showing
signs of recovery and stabilization
there was an quantitative easing program
going on that helped fuel this progress
and then as we approached the 2015
window people started to think maybe the
federal federal government is going to
start unwinding quantitative easing
people's confidence started to rebound
people start to talk a lot more about
jobs right so it says to me that perhaps
this machine has learned something about
the structure of the market and the
overall tone of the sector's and how
they behaved with each other as it
changed from leading into the financial
crisis to the financial crisis to
recovery from the financial crisis to
now so why don't do is I want to take a
moment now to feed this into kensho and
we're gonna ask what happens on days
like February 23rd can we switch to the
demo
yep
cool so we're not a hedge fund we put
out a website we sell our product to
major financial institutions and what
I've done here is extracted the dates
that the machine has told me are similar
I have fed them into our analysis engine
in this case I have 256 previous dates
again you can see the histogram of how
they are clustered by days so I'm going
to ask the system a very specific
question if I buy on the close of days
like February 23rd and I sell it the
next day how do I do so I'm literally
taking on February 23rd I see we're
coming into the close right the markets
are open from 9:30 to 4:00 o'clock
coming into close say it's 3:30 in the
day and I look at the stock prices I
look at my portfolio I look at what's
going on macro levels I look at how the
sectors are performing I look at what's
in the news I run and I ask the Machine
what days are like today and the machine
has told me I found more than 250
precedents like I say if I were to buy
if this ends up being just like how I
think it's gonna shape up over the last
half hour of trading what should I buy
or if I'm already holding it maybe I
should sell reduce my risk reduce my
exposure in this case I'm just gonna do
some liquid ETFs materials energy
consumer discretionary financials
technology stocks the results we can
analyze what happens on all of those
dates we compute on the fly more than 85
different statistics from beta adjusted
returns to p-values to to your actual
raw or average daily returns we adjust
for dividends corporate actions you can
see the dispersion in how the various
market sectors pan out there's not tight
clustering around those events in this
case I'm looking at the beta adjusted
return this helps normalize the
performance of the various sectors
relative to the benchmark so I'm looking
for out performance or under performance
rather than just maybe everything went
up
that given day so what happens so in
this case I'm gonna treat this returns
chart as a stack rank and it seems like
in this case energy has historically
outperformed materials is up there you
have down at the bottom XLF is the
financials i see health care seems to
underperform so in this kind of thing i
might say hey let me look at my holdings
am i am i overweight healthcare should i
do something about that if i was
planning on buying energy should i buy
it today rather than tomorrow
lastly we we give our customers all the
raw data output rerun tests t-test both
1-sided 2-sided depending on the
scenario that you're trying to measure
about looking for fat tail risk and and
looking for shifts in the distribution
of returns we also look a lot about time
series so those way machine learning
teaches us about time series we then
feed that into a visualization that
allows us to appreciate what the machine
has identified and overlay that with how
the market has performed so I do it I'm
going to say sell healthcare and buy
some energy or hedge my positions on the
24th this allows me to do something
different so now I'm actually asking
what happened
I bought some stocks on the clothes and
now I held them and Here I am on the
24th holding these stocks so what
happened to my portfolio
so I see materials has done quite well I
see energy is still up at the top
I see health care has nudged a little
bit I'm not sure if there's something
here but it does seem like the top has
generally stabilized the bottom has
generally stabilized and there's some
shuffling or mixing around in the middle
and it's this kind of thing I've told
the computer almost nothing other than
here's some market data right we remove
what I don't need group it together
removes reduce the dimensionality
identify signals that are passed from
previous States to future States and
then fed that back into an analysis
engine to say well this looks like this
kind of day what happens tomorrow and
when I look at this I say this is not a
random walk we go back to my slides
please
so let's bring this all together what
we're really doing is talking about
understanding the connections of things
right how are things connected to each
other
we're statistically annotating the
significance of what has happened in the
market right so we're looking at to
market assets there's a major a
publicity event a company has earnings
there's unrest in the Middle East
there's a there's a new product
announced by a specific company to what
extent does that influence an alter how
that asset performs in the future
through market assets that means events
happening in the world news happening
now and to what extent does that change
our perception of the likelihood or the
significance of events coming in the
future
and then lastly market assets by
themselves can influence what will
happen as well I'll go back again to the
drop in the price of oil where you can
see how the drop in the price of oil has
caused ramifications in the Middle East
around the structure of those
governments and their ability to pay
their bills it's affected Alaska which
is now having to start considering it
income taxes and change their budget
their budget economics quite
dramatically and ultimately through
machine learning we're answering the
question who should care and how much
and if you decide that you do or don't
care right when when should you care
when is it important when is the time to
act and for how long now I got a very
interesting question this morning as I
was watching the the keynote and the
person next to me asked me about machine
learning and said is this a biological
process or is this a mathematical
process I think that's a fantastic
question because at the top level
machine learning neural networks
especially they behave like a biological
process there's layers to them there's
nuance they incorporate new things as
new data comes in you can incrementally
train your model in the same way that a
child discovering a toy or gravity or
getting to visit the Large Hadron
Collider
incorporates new information into its
already existing perception and
knowledge of the world but if you zoom
in to the micro details of the model
you're trying to back out is this
machine really get it a really fine
stuff that that I can't see and you look
at the individual layers of the model it
starts to look like math it is math
right it's matrices it's numbers and you
can peel apart the layers of say a
neural network and say each layer what
does it know and how does this change
what it knew from the previous layer in
the same way we might test a child in
school to say what did you learn this
year and compare that to how they did
the previous year and this is our brains
as well we think of our brains as a
biological process because they are
right it's it's lots of connections
it's flaws we learn something we unlearn
it later but then you zoom into the
micro detail and our brains are firing
neurons
it's ones and zeroes did it fire or not
and so when I look at how we've analyzed
the connectedness of things in the world
the increasing velocity at which
information comes in we rely
increasingly heavily on the computers to
process this information like the
prodigy that it is at the velocity that
I can't match and it tells me things and
that allows me to delete code replace it
with models that learn and update and
then go back to solving my customers
problems thank you very much
I can I can do some questions I have
about ten minutes if people would like
to ask questions yes
yes
oh so the question is what data did I
use to decide what was similar in the
past in this particular model I was
using pricing volume volatility ranges
moving averages various ETFs
representing various sectors there's a
lot more stuff that you can pull in and
layer increasing nuance on top of these
things for example you might one thing
we frequently do is we'll pull in when
earnings and other major shock level
events will affect an asset the volume
of ETFs has increased and varied over
years so you probably want an ARIMA
model that normalizes some of the
seasonality out of those things there's
there's additional informational sectors
or even want to study something at a
macro level rather in this case I was
looking at something that was very us
centric so one of the things we find
very valuable about being able to run
rapid experiments in the cloud is you
want to pull in more data we can scale
up the computers to do that if the
experiment seems not to be fruitful we
throw that away we didn't have to build
out a huge infrastructure and then
scurry around trying to get teams to
make sure they're always utilizing it
the the second part is it allows us to
study sample sets and then if it looks
promising then we scale up the project
accordingly so I think the big brain is
the compositional style allows us to
inject different features and different
data and play with that and then when we
find something we can iterate on that
have you have you tried feeding this
model with historical data but on
meeting some of the significant you know
days and see if your model could have
predicted those yeah so that's a great
so the question is you know can you
essentially do a in sample out sample
test so you take say 80 or 85 percent of
your days you train on that data and
then you use it as an out-of-sample test
on the other tenth fifteen or twenty
percent of the data in this case I think
you'd want to pull in additional
features in order to do that well so
please don't trade this strategy but at
the same time that's exactly the right
thing
to do and the other nice thing we have
because we have this complement of
machine learning and back testing
analysis we're able to check those
things and then the incremental layering
of machine learning allows you to
constantly incorporate new information
to be like what did I miss yesterday
let me incorporate that what did I get
right let me reinforce that and so the
model of learning is very much fail
quickly do again but machines unlike
maybe humans don't develop like a bias
we don't get hurt our feelings don't get
hurt right if we are constantly wrong
computers don't get discouraged and so
and then their velocity of running
experiments so fast is such a multiplier
that they're able to fail so many times
until they get it right yeah at a scale
that none of us can match Mike so did it
predict February 24th Purdue I think it
got some things right and some things
wrong in that I think the general if you
think of it as like layers of sediment
the the things that were generally doing
well historically were generally toward
the top and things that were doing
poorly were generally toward the bottom
but but I think you'd again want to like
I wouldn't go trade your retirement
account based on that and I think
there's more you could layer in there
but yeah I think it generally it seemed
to have some sorting there and a
sophisticated financial investor would
probably look at some sort of weighted
strategy that would buy some things in a
higher ratio or short other things or
sell things in a various ratio to
potentially hedge or leveraged
opportunity
ah so the question is did it identify
any days that had never happened before
yes so there was a bunch what I what I
did in terms of so we have a precedent
engine right so we look we use machine
learning to identify precedents of when
something has happened like this and if
there aren't many precedents then you
really can't run a test on what has
happened before although it may be
valuable to know it hasn't happened so
when there are small clusters I I just
leave basically throughout ones that
head I think it was just a handful of
days in them because I don't have a
robust statistical way of feeding those
back in to do analysis on those but
certainly say if I were had a dashboard
up that tells me you know going into the
clothes like hey this looks kind of
unprecedent because of these reasons and
why that's something that you know at
the scale of information coming into the
system
no individual could do micro yeah so the
Python code used showed is written
inside a browser and that would trigger
the URL of machine learning library on
Google yes so so the question being you
know so we we do all the questions about
coding in the browser using an I Python
notebook so we will of API as we love
services we love compositional services
so one of things we do is we build our
own services our own models we use
Google services and Google's API and
then that allows our data scientists to
work in and ipython notebook and that
essentially serves as a journal of what
this is and they can pull things in and
we you know if the experiment doesn't
work out we can stash that in and get
repo and someone can pick it up later or
at least learn from that and the so the
way we we do this is we have an API I
didn't show it here that we can kick off
analysis in the background and pull
those back in so instead of the Google
sensor tens of role-based machine
learning framework you have you manage
all your own machine learning models and
we do both
I got just a couple more minutes right
here have you applied your model to
other data sets and just curious as an
experiment other than financials yes
whoo we've certainly played around with
it we're very much focused on financial
information right now the the financial
industry is heavily focused on you know
security it's they very high standards
for robustness throughput the
large-scale data which keeps it
interesting there's there's clients you
know there's an immediate hunger like
answer now and I think that has a lot of
analogs across many different sectors
and datasets we ingest a large variety
of data so it's not just numbers of from
market data but we also do world events
news we have unstructured data that we
parse out and do identify I didn't into
the identification and to kind of tease
out what's connected we feed a lot of
that into our knowledge graph so that we
can understand the connectedness of
things like proverbial you could like
shake the knowledge graph and see what
else shakes and for how much and over
what amount of time and our knowledge
graph has object-oriented a structure to
it that allows us to validate things and
a lot of those annotations are
time-related because we love mapping
things the time series allows us to
throw into matrices and do machine
learning on it microphone
when you're talking about doing machine
learning you're working with historical
data but in the past there were no other
companies doing machine learning on data
in the early 2000s 1990s so how do you
say that your model is valid compared to
historical data when all the financial
institutions are doing this kind of
analysis now sure it's so there's so the
question being that lots of people are
doing this and I think it's true
you know for example Google's been doing
this for quite a long time right and I
think a big chunk of machine learning is
knowing what to pay attention to and
letting the computer advise that and I
think a lot of what's going to
revolutionize the finance industry and
many other industries as well is they're
going to move to the cloud they're going
to use machine learning to remove code
they're gonna use machine learning to
analyze data they're going to do it in
near to real-time and then the humans
will be enlightened as a result of that
so it flips that like teacher-student
relationship right as an engineer I'm so
used to basically spelling out a recipe
for the computer do a then B then C or
tape you know call a and then call
beyond that or call C on that and and
this flips the rhythm so now it's rather
than a couple people trying to teach a
lot of machines we basically say here's
the framework and data for the machines
to to learn and then they will teach us
and that I think is an immensely
powerful paradigm switch that flips
everything there was another question
back there
I got Tomatoes last last time I had been
playing with Watson and the ability to
actually type in a question and then it
understands the semantics of what you
are asking or the context of what you're
asking and gives you an answer have you
built any of that into your product and
have you leveraged any of Google's
machine learning algorithms to do that
yeah so so we love natural language
processing I think it's a very intuitive
way we search is a very powerful tool
for us and for the financial industry
the we have a query engine where you can
type in more
free forum questions the where I think
it becomes exponentially powerful is I
shouldn't have to ask the computer so
we're evolving from a world that says
computer what about this what about this
what about this and it behaves like
hunt-and-peck
and we're coming to a world was they
know like computer just let me know when
it's important when I should care for
how much and how long and so I think
they both play off to each other the
other area where we use a lot of NLP is
on the ingestion side to identify things
and you can use hidden Markov models to
pull out structure and implications
without even nestling and meeting
identity identification so there's a lot
of cool stuff coming out there and
Google's a major leader in that area
especially on the Texas side all right
last one
yes so the question is do we sell the
final product or do we perhaps sell
pieces of it in the interest we do both
I mean so we're building a platform that
is very flexible has many layers to it
we can scale separately we you know we
follow the Google GCP model of Micra
services and being able to expose those
to have the right layer of abstraction
and we potentially open those up as they
become ready cool thank you so much
everyone
you